whenever people ask me what my favorite
spreads are in the book it's a little
bit like which are your favorite
children you sort of love them all for
different reasons one of the ones is
kind of emerged in the course of doing
the project is someone just anecdotally
was in our office we dated showed me a
presentation they were given giving and
in the presentation was this picture of
the old FBI filing system from the 50s
of the women with little file card
catalogs in this vast sort of you know
warehouse and I thought it's such a cool
picture and so much the opposite of our
idea of how we store data today and then
someone showed me a picture of Julian
Assange's a data center a hundred feet
underground and Sweden which had similar
shape so I thought this is really cool
these are file catalogs and here are
these you know huge data servers and
then I thought I wonder if there's some
story about Jagger Hoover that time
magazine did as a hero back then and we
found this wonderful time magazine cover
and of course back then he was a hero he
was the head of the FBI saving the free
world and now we found out that in fact
she was using a lot of this information
for his own personal purposes and then
up then we found a Time magazine cover
with Julian Assange you know basically
being very critical of him and you know
saying he was destroying you know it's
very interesting to me what I'm I wonder
50 years from now we'll look back maybe
Julian will be the hero and Jade groover
will be the enemy of the state that time
changes the way that we understand
perspective so I thought that the way
that page evolved was interesting and
the last thing that I thought about it
was really fun was that somebody made a
comment that in fact the data center
where the WikiLeaks data is stored is
actually much more vulnerable to attack
than the FBI filing system which you
couldn't have gotten in there and if you
did get in there there were no Xerox
machines and there's certainly no thumb
drives so the fact that you know that
all this data that actually ended up in
WikiLeaks was basically snuck out on you
know a cd-rom or on little thumb drives
would have been impossible back in the
50s so that was actually more secure
even though it's much less accessible so
the page has this wonderful sort of
echoes back and forth through technology
and space and time and politics and
history and it's one of my favorites
president
you